good morning believe nation today's
message is be perceptive over to you
Mindy Kaling it is very important to be
expressive and so much that no one
should ever be stopping you from saying
what you need to say or you should never
have that fear however I think as a
young person it's equally important if
not more important to be perceptive and
to be sensitive and I feel like we don't
talk about that a lot
because we feel like the only way to
show that we're empowered is by speaking
in and I think that you know when I was
growing up I really thought that what my
parents taught me it was like I largely
I didn't talk until I was like 15 years
old I was pretty much silent which no
one believes and it's because I just was
like listening and paying attention to
what everyone was saying and and and you
know trying to have a good social IQ
which I think helped me become a really
would help me later to become a writer
and I think that that is the the one
biggest thing is to really you know to
listen to others more than necessarily
putting such a premium on being able to
say how what you feel so what do you
think first I love Mindy I love her
story I love where she comes from I know
people who've read her books and we
always talk about how what a smart
person she is and I think she's a
fantastic young female role model so so
what I'm gonna say comes from all of
that stuff
but I think I think her point is is so
valid today because when I think about
my kids I have four kids ranging from
like nine down when I think of them
being a teenager and I think of them in
their 20s and all of the social
pressures I think we just spend so much
time feeling like we need to prove
ourselves to others like like if we do
certain things if we live a certain
lifestyle if we live the lifestyle that
we think that we need to live for
Facebook that that will be happy and
what I took away from it is just give
yourself permission to watch others to
listen to others to spend time take take
the time to just watch what's going on
in the war
around you and learning from others
before you hit the ground running trying
to show everyone what you can do that
may not have been her message but that's
what I took away from it
I'm a little conflicted I mean I think
obviously the message of be perceptive
is something that can help you as an
entrepreneur if you understand yourself
to know your strengths and weaknesses
and create a business around that if you
understand your customers and what
they're looking to do why they're buying
your product what they care about
listening to then create great products
you know great salespeople are the best
listeners to understand your staff and
build a culture that they want to be a
part of and understand what their needs
are I think all of that helps tie in
here's the conflict I have is if you're
not perceptive then what do you do is it
that I want to try to get more
perceptive because my instinct tells me
you know what don't worry about it go
all in on what you're good at you know
like if I am if my passion is you know
for cars and I'm a great race car driver
and that's what I want to be at and I
can just be the best racecar driver ever
and I'm not great at dealing with people
and I'm not great at you know maybe
building a team do I want to work on
those things I do want to work on just
like being the best race car driver
everybody's my thing right so like I
feel it helps it can help you as an
entrepreneur as a person but if I'm not
that do I want to work on that to be
better at it or just going in on my
strengths so it's my default advice to
be going on what you're really good at I
forget what the point is to take the
time and give yourself permission and
take the months or years to watch others
and learn from others not worry about
sitting down taking notes quick download
everything and then I'm gonna go run off
on tactical things I'm gonna go run off
on action I'm gonna go run off and start
putting things into place and so so if
you want to be the best racecar driver
the best thing to do is to watch you
know model the masters watch how the
best race car drivers live how they eat
what their fitness is you know and learn
all of those things and involve yourself
into that world if that's what you want
and when I think back in terms in terms
of my my personal background
you know my grandfather who's in his
late 80s now started a business with
four partners in 1950
and watching him live his life going on
walks hearing stories all of those
things shaped the the very values that
that I bring to my business I have these
flashes in my mind where I'm like ah
that's where I learned this from this
person this is where I learned this from
from my mother or so on and and I think
you know being aware of those moments as
they're happening and holding on to them
and giving yourself permission to not
just take it run with it and go off and
start doing tactical things is is the
lesson and and I think that it's not
obvious I think a lot of people are
worried about getting going I mean I
love the message I try to apply to my
life I see it totally in terms of
building a team in projects and
customers and media and suppliers it
fits well with Who I am
I'm just thinking the people who aren't
is it worth going all-in on trying to
improve yourself on that versus doing
what you're good at focusing on that
even though you may be totally clueless
to how the rest of the world works and
you don't pay attention to your team or
the you know maybe you don't have a team
or you know I don't know I just it's
okay I'm conflicted I'm conflicted it's
not extraordinary as what he's saying
yeah I'm conflicted on this point
and that's it so the question of the day
today is what do you think Evan was kind
of like it's okay I was like and I love
this clip do you agree with him do you
agree with me to have your own thoughts
let us know in the comments below
cool I'm really excited to see what you
guys write so that's it thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
nespresso TV go